dhs secretary mayorkas says he's going
to travel to our southern border where
you've seen thousands of people
streaming across as the administration
ramps up deportations now they're
sending people back to haiti
all right this comes as agents on the
ground are grappling with more than 14
000 migrants uh which if they enter the
country will be illegal immigrants
camped under a bridge in del rio texas
and that's where fox and friends
enterprise reporter lawrence jones joins
us good morning
hey good morning family uh the border is
still at crisis no sign of the president
of the united states he's still
vacationing the borders our kamala
harris is flipping coins at football
games uh she's not here
dealing with what's happening on the
ground the only way i can describe this
and i did a tour yesterday
at ground zero where all of this is
playing out is it's not just a crisis
but it was a preventable crisis and and
i can only tell you this the cartel is
winning in this battle
they are still having people go across
the texas dps shut down part of the
border and they find another way to get
across
right here behind me is the legal port
of entry you see a lot of commerce
coming there a lot of people coming here
to work that's now shut down you cannot
go in or come out because the the
situation is that dire
we're still trying to figure out what
the biden administration is going to do
right now panic is here
you see a lot of the dps coming through
a lot of border patrol coming through
reinforcements uh because they are
afraid that the folks that are there and
these are haitian immigrants but they
they've been in south america for 10 and
15 years just waiting for their chance
um they're afraid that they have gotten
word that they're going to be deported a
lot of these folks will be deported
because of because of our current
immigration law and they don't know what
they're going to do so that's why you
see this in uh bound traffic of more
assistance heading your way
all right lawrence jones live in del rio
where they supposedly have stopped the
flow of migrants although it doesn't
really look like it lawrence thank you
thank you lawrence people were saying
it's hard to find water and food for
those individuals there's garbage
everywhere people are sleeping on the
dirt yeah six thousand were there by
wednesday uh excuse me nine thousand
there by wednesday another six thousand
over the weekend we're over fourteen
thousand and most of them from
haiti originally but most came from
countries in between chile and brazil
they were there there and they said hey
i heard it's a great time to go to
america joe biden's president and they
did border patrol discovered 49
undocumented immigrants inside a
tractor-trailer they had the k-9 unit
out there and the dogs smelled that
something was suspicious they opened up
the tractor trailer there were 49
individuals in there from brazil ecuador
el salvador honduras guatemala mexico
and peru and so many from haiti because
the president gave the haitians a
temporary protective status and that's
why they said okay